Aceable is an education
focused company
delivering what we call
required education,
or high stakes learning,
through mobile devices.
About nine months ago now,
I sat down with an advisor.
He was like, you basically
don't have a company worth
investing in.
The idea of mobile
makes a lot of sense.
The idea of using game
mechanics makes a lot of sense.
And even content and education
makes a lot of sense,
but the material
that we were offering
at that point, none of
it was have to have.
You could go find
out about pregnancy
from 1,000 different sources.
You didn't have to buy it.
So this guy gave me
a lot of good advice.
He said, go focus on areas where
people have to learn things.
And deliver that content
through mobile with game
mechanics in a
social, fun manner.
So last July that's what
we started focusing on.
Nine months later we
released a driver's ed app
that actually gets
you full certification
in the State of Texas from
a driver's ed standpoint.
Looking back on times when
things are really hard,
the only way we turned
the corner was really
just sheer persistence.
Raising money, we raised a half
a million dollars at Christmas
time when people told me there
was no way it could be done.
And the only way
was persistence.
And I think I've
perfected writing
the email where it says,
I hope you don't take
my persistence as
being annoying,
it's just I'm sure
you know how it is.